i didn't know any spells excuse us  if he didn't know any spells then why  was he whipping out this curse  [Music]  well the truth is it was a grip on set  who inspired the vicious spell choice  when i'm playing him i have absolute  belief that i'm right isaacs knew he had  to do a spell but being so new to the  franchise he didn't know any yet so a  group suggested this one so i started to  say vada canaveral there's nothing that  he wouldn't do he's got that right the  actor has paid the price though fans  weren't going to let this one slide i  got a mailbag from thousands and  thousands of people people are still  annoyed about it poor isaacs might never  live this unfortunate improvised lying  down